(Subtle grunting from Bob, along with heavy breathing.)
Mark: Bob?
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Factorio!
With Bob. Hi, Bob!
Bob: And oil!
Mark: AND OIL!
Mark: OOIL; As long as you have the right OIL...
Mark: Oh yeah, explain this. Explain this...
Bob: Umm... hehehehe
Mark: ... thing.
Bob: You're such a jerk.
Mark: Why?
Bob: Alright, so...
Mark: You built it!
Bob: ... the way this works
Bob: Yeah, this was actually my idea.
Bob: I don't know how it works though. So this is not...
Bob: So these little puddles of crude oil on the ground,
Bob: you stick on of these green pump jacks on there and it
Bob: sucks it up out of there
Mark: Uh huh.
Bob:  shoves it in this pipe here .. umm.. and it
Bob:puts it into this big thing that Mark is standing next to
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: This is called "Oil Refinery Rhys Nielsen."
Mark: Rhitt... Rhizsas Nielzon!
Mark: Rhiz Nielzen.
Mark: Okay.
Mark: So, when you click on it, ...
Bob: Uhh... it's refining oil?
Mark: Yeah, no. You click on it and it's got assembly.
Mark: It's basic oil processing and NOW it's going.
Bob: Ohhhhh... oohhh...
Mark: Cool!
Bob: I was wondering why it wasn't doing anything.
Mark: Nice! So now it's gonna make, uh,
Bob: Oh, so these other storage tanks are for different types of oil.
Mark: OOH!
Bob: And they're absolutely unnecessary.
Mark: No, no, they're perfect!
Mark: It's-no-it's gonna make all of them!
Mark: It made all of them! Oh, wait, y-your one... No-no..
Bob: No, it only made the one.
Mark: No, your one down here is connected to the other so you need to move it over just a little bit.
Mark: This needs to move
Bob: Oh balls, okay.
Mark: I got it.
Mark: You almost had it perfect but this is good.
Mark: Hang on
Bob: Good enough!
Mark: So that-that's there and then this goes like such as that
Mark: See? And now we got three different products!
Bob: Such as..
Bob: Look at that shit!
Mark: YEAH!!
Mark: I don't know what to do with them but YEAH!! (Chuckle)
Bob: Yeah I don't even honestly know what oil is for...
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: But I assume that we want it because it's oil..
Mark: Yeah, so this one has petroleum gas, this one has light oil, and this one has heavy oil.
Mark: Which is...
Mark: Gooooooooooooood????
Bob: Don't be- don't be mad.. don't be mad..
Mark: 'Caus-
Mark: What why would I be mad?
Bob: No reason..
Mark: Why would I-
Mark: When you say "Don't be mad" that just leads me to think..
Bob: Don't be mad! Don't be mad!
Bob: It's okay! Don't be mad!
Mark: I'm-I'm not mad if you just talk to me, like converse emotionally like we need to-
Bob: Just, just Mark don't be mad
Mark: I-I'm-uh-I'm- I'm not mad.
Mark: I'm-I'm-I'm not gettin' mad. I'm..
Bob: You're just disappointed?
Mark: (Laughing) I'm just disappointed- okay.
Bob: (Laughing)
Mark: There's another thing called a Chemical Plant which I'm going to put down- little below it.
Mark: Right
Mark: Here
Mark: So let me rotate that actually
Bob: I'm gonna- I'm gonna get a third pump jack going, 'cause why not?
Mark: Okay, cool.
Mark: Okay.
Mark: Cool.
Bob: There we go!
Mark: Okay so the Chemical Plant
Mark: Can turn
Mark: These things into other things..
Mark: So if we puuummmmpppp
Mark: Let's say, I'm going to pump the crude oil.
Mark: Into one end.
Bob: Oh my gosh I think this has accelerated our pollution
Bob: Holy shit!
Mark: Holy shit
Mark: Has it?
Bob: Also, if you- if you hit map and scroll all the way out
Mark: Yeah?
Bob: Does the darkness- does the black edges- is that the entire world?
Mark: Dude, the world is infinite. There is no limit.
Bob: Oh my god
Bob: I think I just peed my pants a little bit.
Mark: (Grunts then laughs)
Mark: (Deep voice) Oh my god
Mark: Okay so we need more storage tanks on the other side because this is going to make
Bob: Alright I'll build some more storage tanks
Mark: Yeaaahhh
Mark: So right now I'm going to have it make solid fuel.
Mark: Oh! You can have it make solid fuel out of anything!
Mark: Aah! Oh ho ho ho ho
Bob: Really?
Mark: Yeah!
Mark: So right now it's making solid fuel out of petroleum gas and you can have a different Chemical plant
Mark: Wait let me see if it can do two different ones it might be able to.
Bob: Now I've got double storage-
Bob: Double storage on there
Mark: We probably need to do uh- ground pipes because this is gonna be hard to walk around if it's all just gobbed up.
Bob: Oh.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Yeah, that's probably a good idea.
Mark: But you're- you're the king!
Bob: I'll make some ground pipes.
Bob: I'll start- I'll start replacing, I'll start replacing.
Mark: Okay good
Mark: But yeah this is cool because now we have uh- solid fuel is being made out of the- OH OKAY.
Mark: So the out put of this is solid fuel so these storage tanks at the bottom aren't necessary just yet.
Mark: Um, that's for advanced refinery when we have more stuff to refine from it.
Mark: But THIS IS GOOD!
Bob: We're doing stuff! Man, I didn't know oil refining was so easy!
Mark: I thiiiiinnnnnnnkkkkkk
Mark: (Laughing)
Mark: If I had known that.. I think could be possible.
Bob: sooo easy
Mark: Oo, but we can make plastic in this thing
Mark: YEAH! WE CAN MAKE PLASTIC!
Mark: We have-ch-It just needs coal
Mark: And
Mark: Uh-uh- This stuff and we-
Bob: Take a breath, take a breath
Mark: Bu-bl-beh BEHIH BEHIB
(Taking a breath.)
Mark: We got coal right here!
Bob: (Imitating Mark's breathing.)
Mark: We have coal right here we can get coal in there!
Mark: THERE'S COAL RIGHT HERE!!
Mark: RIGHT HERE THERE'S COAL!
Mark: Hang on I just blew up everything.
Bob: Do you have any coal in there?
Mark: Hang on! Shh. Hang on wh- I just- I just destroyed everything
Bob: Wow you really did just ruin- you just ruined everything
Mark: Shut uuppp!
Mark: I didn't!
Mark: And there and then- (inaudible)
Bob : And there and look at that!
Bob: Look at all that underground pipe-work I just did!
Mark: WOW!
Bob: I saved us
Mark: (Laughing)
Bob: SEVERAL FEET OF GROUND SPACE LOOK!
Mark: (Still laughing)
Bob: Mark, look!
Bob: Ahhh UM! (Humming circus tune)
Mark: I'm lookin' at it!
Mark: WOW, BOB!
Mark: HOORAY!
Bob: Hang on it's not done! It's not done- I figured out- I figured out some more stuff watch this!
Mark: Okay, alright, I'm ready.
Bob: Eyya!
Bob: Ahh! Look at that! Look how open it is!
Mark: WOW!
Mark & Bob: (Humming the circus tune)
Bob: (Still humming the circus tune..)
Mark: Okay, that- that's really nice, Bob that is really nice
Bob: THANKS, DAD!
Mark: (Laughing) That's a good job, Bob! I'm really proud of ya son!
Bob: (Laughs)
Mark: You did great work!
Bob: You know what?
Mark: (Grunts)
Bob: I am proud of this.
Mark: I-I'm lagging so bad I'm not even moving- OH god there I go!
Bob: (Laughing)
Mark: One of these days we're gonna fix this lag but right now I'm just gonna live with it apparently.
Mark: I've got no other choice besides that.
Bob: Eh there's no, there's no fixing that shit that's just how it is.
Mark: Okay so, these storage tanks are stupid and they don't work and you should feel bad for making them, But!
Mark: We have inserters and shit.
Bob: Okay, well I'll just keep that then.
Bob: Just- okay.
Mark: Yeah, just give up on your dreams of what ever the hell happened here
Mark: And uh.
Bob: So where- how do we get the stuff out of there?
Mark: Like that!
Bob: How do we get the stuff out of there?
Mark: Like that!  It's going so slow.. we're run- we're out of power, everything's out of power.
Bob: Ohhhh
Mark: Oh God! (Laughing)
Bob: Oh everythings out of power?? (Laughing)
Mark: Look how slow it's going!
Bob: I'll go- I'll go fill it up
Mark & Bob: (Laughing)
Bob: You know, I think we just need to fire em' I think that's the solution.
Mark: Awh, come on! Reggie is doing okay!
Mark: He's not doing his weird dance, he's just moving feebly and slow!
Mark: (High pitched, squeaky voice) It's okay, It's alright! It's cool!
Mark: You don't need to worry about it!
Mark: Okay so now though we can make,
Bob: Man everything was completely out of fucking coal
Mark: Yeah? wow okay so coal has a value of 8 mega jewels.
Mark: The solid fuel has a value of 25 mega jewels so it's about three times more..
Bob: Oh my god we need to get that solid fuel into shit.
Mark: Yeah! like the steam engine!
Mark: So I guess the oil- the oil refinery's are only for fueling steam engines but I guess we don't need water anymore?
Mark: No we need water to pump, that's right we still need water, yeah.
Bob: The waters for the steam, yeah.
Mark: We're always gonna need water but yeah.
Bob: Pretty crucial.
Mark: A little bit not- not quite un-crucial, yeah I gotcha' yeah I understand.
Bob: Steam water
Mark: Okay,
Bob: Man.
Bob: Plastic bar
Bob: Look at that!
Mark: Yeaah! Not bad!
Mark: Just slow on the-
Bob: Wait so I thought- I thought you said we were making solid fuel?
Mark: Uhm..
Mark: We were- we can make solid fuel out of any of these other ones.
Bob: You mean the- you mean. Ohh, okay.
Mark: Both the light oil and heavy oil can be made into solid fuel.
Mark: So we just need to pump those out to their separate Chemical Plants.
Bob: Oh okay.
Mark: And then they're good.
Mark: Understood?
Mark: (Whispers) Nice
Mark: This is nice, this is real nice.
Bob: Good work everybody!
Mark: Oh wow,
Mark: I can't believe we're doing it! Like this is real stuff.
Bob: I know!
Mark: Like this is really real.
Bob: This is the thing, man!
Mark: Yeah! Okay so.
Bob: We're- we're- really gonna be under attack...
Bob: Well, it's not spreading as fast as I thought it would. But, it's- we're not- it's.
Mark:  (High pitched voice) eehhhh it's FINE
Bob: They're-they're gonna be mad at us.
Mark: It's probably like- eh- well it's giving us in our favor is that every once in a while our steam engines just shut off
Mark: (Laughing) And that saves us!
Bob: (Laughing) Yeah!
Bob: "It just saves us"
Mark & Bob: (Laughing)
Mark: So that we don't have to worry about it! 'Cause it's totally fine!
Bob: So.. it's on purpose?
Bob: It's on purpose?
Mark: Yeah!
Mark: It's totally on purpose!
Bob: Or the steam engines are supposed to shut off.
Bob: Because then.. we don't.. pollute.. so much..?
Mark: Yeah, we're like con- conserving the environment! That's how you say that word..
Bob: Con-sor-ving
Mark: We're Con-swerving the en-viron-ment.
Mark: OH! Why does the- why does the pipe only go straight? That's stupid.
Bob: So what's uh-
Mark: That's stupid!
Bob: It doesn't- oh the underground?
Mark & Bob: Yeah
Bob: That's why it's like that, I'm not just an idiot.
Mark & Bob: (Laughs)
Mark: I- (Laughs)
Bob: I understand the idea that it would be really convenient to bend the pipes underground.
Mark: (Still laughing)
Bob: I'm familiar with the concept.
Mark: and I
Mark: And I-I understand the desire to call me an idiot, but. Just-like I'm not..
Mark: Just wanna reiterate that
Mark: I'm not..no
Bob: So now you're making solid fuel? Ahh.
Mark: Yeah!
Mark: So now I'm making solid fuel I'm gonna put it another steel chest over here.
Bob: Oh.
Mark: Everything- Okay! Fine! You do it!
Bob: I was gonna- okay
Mark: Or YOU could make the other chemical pla- NO! I'll do that TOO.
Mark: FINE!
Mark: WHATEVER!
Mark: Geez..
Bob: Hey look- I made it- I made it in a steel chest.
Mark: Ooooyyyy meehfbe
Bob: Actually, it's an iron chest. But whatever.
Mark: Okay whatever.
Mark: Now this ones producing.. from the light..
Mark: Man! Oil is really useful! Holy crap!
Mark: So much stuff!
Bob: Yeah! That shit's awesome!
Mark: Oh yeah? Well I got a steel chest, and I got a faaaast doo-daddy.
Mark: Heh!
Mark: Look at your pathetic little thing!
Mark: It doesn't need to be this fast.
Bob: Yeah, yours is just like "WOOOH"
Mark: (Laughs)
Bob: WOOOH!
Mark: It's just reaaallly excited about doing oil processing!
Bob: (Laughing)
Mark: But no this is cooool!
Bob: This is awesome! Now we just need the research to finish so we can get-
Mark: It's..
Bob: Logistics robots to take all of the- the- uh- ha- oh- solid fuel into the boilers.
Mark: Yeaah!!
Bob: So we don't have to do that shit.
Mark: I wonder if it can fly that far, that's the big question.
Bob: I fucking hope so.
Bob: But- I mean we can create like relay points.
Mark: Yeah- I mean we could just belt this instead of having it be in a box we could just belt it all the way down.
Mark: But that would take forever.
Bob: That would be.. that would take a lot of belts.
Mark: That's a- that's a lot of belt, I don't wanna
Bob: N stuff.. or we producing science?
Bob: Now, we were just not producing copper for I don't know how long.
Mark: Oh yeah?
Mark: Oh yeah! 'Cause those still run on.. coal? That's right.
Bob: (Laughs) The furnaces were empty..
Mark: Well yeah because you don't have a coal supply over there! Ya dingus!
Mark: And you got these two..
Bob: Well there's not any coal near by..
Mark: And you- you also have like these two electric mining jewels that just aren't doing anything 'cause they're out of mine.
Mark: But, that's cool.
Bob: Whatever!
Mark: It's fine!
Bob: I'll-I'm gonna run a coal supply over here since you're being... a dillhole.. about it..
Mark: Oh, OH NOW we start fighting?
Bob: Since you've-
Mark: (Laughs)
Bob: Since you've been a dillhole about it!
Bob: (Mumbling)
Mark: Oh Bob! I didn't hear what you said but I feel really insulted
Bob: Eck Eck Eck! That's how I feel about you!
Mark: (Laughing)
Mark: Oh no..
Bob: That's how I feel about you right now!
Mark: Aww.. I feel so bad- Hey this is- Nice!
Bob: I'm actually gonna do a fast conveyer belt. 'Cause fuck you.
Mark: Nice!... Well.. ME? I'm-I'm on board with that! I'm 100% okay with fast!
Bob: Yeah!
Mark: Fast is good!
Bob: Doing it just to spite you!
Mark: I-uh- Okay? I guess?
Mark: I'm okay with this spiting but you know- okay..
Mark: Actually, this is really cool because we have sooo much science goin' on here.
Bob: Eh- I don't-  I don't have a reason that I'm so upset
Mark: I've- I'm literally like maxing out the capacity for these labs to hold.
Bob: We're sciencing the fuck out of this!
Mark: Yeeaah!
Bob: We're not sciencing the shit out of this, we're sciencing the fuck out of it.
Mark: Yeah! And that's actually really good because that means that we left the science makers alone and they still produced a lot of science, so.
Bob: They continued to function!
Mark: (Laughs) It's like "I didn't blow up!" it is good! Yeah, man!
Bob: It's like fucking magic! Man!
Mark: Nicee
Mark: I'm actually j- I'm really tickled every time I look at this like
Mark: Eh- I'ma zoom out for everyone to enjoy like the entirety of what we've made like
Mark: From the start of the point where we're recording in this session and this might be the last episode that we record in this bunch, but.
Mark: We've done a lot!
Mark: We've done a whole lot!
Bob:  Well yeah!
Mark: Like-
Bob: Yeah we've accomplished so many things!
Mark: Like, holy shit! look at all that, we've got oil processing, we've got iron production out the ass!
Mark: Wh- just so much iron production, we've got-
Mark: All this copper production, we got science, we got science one and two, we've got- Y'know Bob's little piddly pathetic science- Hey!
Mark: Look- I'm gonna-I'm gonna check to see how much science this has produced in that one.
Bob: Can we please just tear them down?! For fuck sake.
Mark: 'Cause the other one-
Bob: NEVER! NONE! IT HAD NOTHING!
Mark: The benchmark- yeah actually the iron chest is empty.. (Laughs)
Bob: IT'S DEAD!
Mark: There is no science in it! (Laughs)
Bob: FUCK!
Mark: But you know..
Bob: Fuckin'
Mark: It's-
Mark: It's something!
Mark: Even the- even the red one is kinda not doing anything. But you know it's cool!!
Bob: The red one was also pretty broken, so that's not that surprising to me.
Mark: Oh, okay alright then I didn't want to burst your bubble too badly. But that's good.
Bob: No, the red one is also awful, don't worry.
Mark: Yeah might have- we actually have so much science I'm gonna make more labs, I'm gonna make six more labs.
Bob: Oh cool,  great, excellent!
Bob: I'm glad that your science is working out so well.
Mark: Yeah!
Mark: Thank you- it's- it's-
Bob: You know, I told him how to do that!
Mark: You didn't- you helped- admittedly!
Bob: (Laughs)
Mark & Bob: (Laughing)
Bob: You didn't even know how to respond!
Mark: (Still laughing)
Bob: (Mocking Mark) "You didn't! You- your- oof- uh- wait- but!
Bob: Science!"
Mark: You- you helped! I will admit you helped! You did help when I got stumpled!
Mark: You did great. Wow- that fast belt is moving quick.
Bob: Yeeaah! It's fast!
Mark: Super fast!
Bob: like da sanic!
Mark: Oh- I see what you're doing there.
Mark: I see
Mark: Ah, okay! Nice!
Bob: Yeah I'm just gonna feed it into this shit, then there will be coal.
Mark: Nice.
Mark: NICE.
Bob: Niceee
Bob: Uuuh
Mark: It might be more beneficial to put it on the other side but whatever
Mark: It's cool.
Mark: It's whatever.
Bob: (Sighs) like- uh- what?
Bob: Fine.
Mark: (Laughs) No, you don't have to redo everything!
Mark: You just have to- okay, alright.
Bob: No- I- I'm gonna switch it around, as suggested.
Mark: You do your- (laughs)
Bob: AH SHIT! Tree, why you doing this to me?
Mark: (Laughing)
Mark: Okay, whatever.
Bob: It was the trees! It wasn't me, it was the trees!
Mark: Ah- yeah- sure- whatever.
Mark: Okay so we are- we are all out of time for this episode- actually no I'm gonna put the- oh no I'm not even close to done making the labs.
Bob: Baseball.
Mark: So yeah- we're all the time and I-wh- time.
Mark: Fuck.
Mark: We're all done.
Mark: (Frustrated)
Mark: We're all out of time for this episode.
Bob: Well that's it- work it all- I'm an idiot.
Mark: SEE?
Mark: TOLD YA!
Bob: Just... just leave me alone.
Mark: No you j- you're almost- you're almost there you just gotta make one more uh back from the yellow belt.
Mark: And then you gotta
Mark: THEN you can put it on top of the thing and it'll just dump on.
Bob: ... what?
Mark: You gotta move the yellow belt one more back.
Mark: And then
Mark: Er- add one more, right- right where I'm standing here.
Mark: And then you can curve the red on to the top
Mark: of the second one line- one more line- no, one more line down-
Bob: No but it's
(Silence)
Bob: I don't understand what you're saying can you just do it?
Mark: I don't have any red..
Mark: And I'm in the middle of making labs.
Mark: So, yeah like get this up.
Mark: Over
Mark: And then down on to this part.
Bob: Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh, o.
Mark: Yeah
Mark: There you go!
Bob: Like this?
Mark: Yeaah!
Mark: You get- you doin' it Bob! you help-ted!
Mark: You're helping!
Mark: no nO NO NO ONE MORE OVER! ONE MORE OVER!
Bob: IT DIDN'T WORK!
Mark: You're almost- you're so
Bob: Like this and then down?
Mark: Yes!
Mark: There!
Mark: YEAH!
Bob: I DID IT!
Mark: YOU DID IT!
Mark: I'm so proud of you, son.
Mark: I'm so proud.
Mark: That- that thing really books it holy shit.
Bob: I did it!
Bob: Yeah it does, it's gonna be fucking backed up with coal- charc- with coal over here.
Bob: Like in five seconds..
Mark: Yeah
Mark: Okay, so I'm going to make a lab center labooze- labooze.
Bob: Lab boobs?
Mark: Fuck.
Mark: Stupid lag.
Bob: I wish I could ride the conveyer belt through the underground conveyor belt.
Bob: That'd be like the ultimate theme park ride-
Mark: That..
Mark: Have you tried it?
Bob: I just did.. it didn't work..
Mark: Shit.
Mark: I'm so sorry.
Bob: Also, you've made a big hole in the wall.
Mark: I didn't know- I didn't- Oh yeah that's the one I tore down with my bare hands after I died.
Bob: When you died and you had to claw your way back in.
Mark: (Laughs)
Mark: I remember!
Mark: It was a nightmare!
Bob: (Laughs)
Mark: Alright we gotta like split up the- uh- split up the science packs into these labs but I'm lagging so badly that it's just not working!
Mark: Alright there we go!
Mark: It's in there.
Mark: It's in there
Mark: Can you get some red ones out of my red?
Bob: Yes, you mean- the functioning red one?
Mark: Ah- ei-either one- they both work great and we're out of power again. FUCK!
Mark: God damnit!
Bob: Laughs
Mark: So thank you everybody so much for watching, we're gonna progress on this in another session probably down the road.
Mark: I don't know, Bob. Do you still have time?
Bob: Maybe one more.
Mark: We can do one more! Okay! We might do  one more! So-
Mark: Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always we'll see you in the next video! BYE BYE!!
(Mark in the background) You can't ever defeat me! I might but not even as fast! a little bit of HETHE!
(Mark in the background) I'm wearing them! (laughter) That's my crotch! I got it!